okay so we met some of your alter egos  last time you were on the show  you know when we could see people in  person um but have you developed any new  characters because quarantine would  provide you time for that  well i didn't i haven't developed any  new characters but  there was a resurgence of one of my oh  my god hold on one second he can join us  watch  this hey okay i love her  she's so great oh my god  okay so this is mikayla my name is  miguel  and i make videos with him and at the  beginning of the pandemic  yeah there he is at the beginning of the  pandemic let's cross his legs so he can  yeah he's sophisticated yeah  but i do it for my people  i love you yeah mikael maybe he'll join  us for the rest of this  i love his legs crossed that's it's the  little touches it's the god is in the  details it's very important  that's awesome  you